right off the bat I can name six names
it connects pedophilia to one of the
major studios the way that he would
threaten me was like you know if you
tell your parents what's going on you
tell your mom and you're not gonna be
able to hack anymore many of the adults
in there know each other and are
exchanging information about certain
kids frightening you got to realize how
many Studios may have protected people
that he knew what they were doing wrong
they don't want to get rid of people
because they're making money for them
in the city where dreams are made we now
know Fame can come at a price
power and money can buy silence and even
the conviction for child abuse doesn't
necessarily preclude you from the party
I have heard many stories of kids going
to an age an agent who can control their
career and put them into auditions and
so the agents spending time alone with
the child they're able to sort of
unfortunately get them away from
parental supervision and then they take
advantage of these kids and it's more
common I think than we can even imagine
if you'd asked me when I was five years
old what I wanted to be when I grew up
it was I wanted to be famous
Nathan Winters was 11 when he starred in
his first film some of the cast and crew
came to my mom and said you know Nathan
and Victor's interaction on set is not
okay
there's something going on director
victor salva had been a friend of
Nathan's mum since Nathan was six she
made props for his movies French clown
house financed by Francis Ford Coppola
was his first feature film and behind
the scenes something awful was happening
his grooming process was developing my
love and trust and developing my parents
trust and so essentially he became a
close friend in the family and it turned
in from like you know well how would I
take Nathan for a few hours tonight you
know give you guys a break and then that
eventually within a year turned into
full weekends the first time that I
remember there and being any kind of
touching or abuse I was staying the
night at his house his apartment and we
were watching movies in one of the
movies he put on to watch was Jungle
Book and started talking about Mowgli's
loincloth and so that he could make me
one so he got two bandanas and tied them
together and made this loincloth and as
he's tying him he's like fondling me and
and that's like my first memory of when
the abuse started and you know
eventually it progressed over the next
five years video tape all of it I mean
it was it was full-blown
when they found out Nathan's family went
to the police and Salva was eventually
sent to prison he had a nice expensive
lawyer team there was people watching us
and and again I think that there was no
intent other than to make it aware that
we were being watched and to intimidate
us and hopefully scare us off as a
convicted pedophile victor salva is on
the sex offenders register but it hasn't
stopped him having a successful career
in movies
powder one of the scripts he wrote in
prison was distributed by Disney's Buena
Vista pictures what's your name he's
also made the Jeepers Creepers franchise
I was told at 12 that I'd never work in
that industry again basically
blackballed for telling the truth
he's been coddled completely by certain
members of Hollywood and and big names
in Hollywood have been backing him and
throughout the entire process it just
seems like there's like an exclusive
club and Victor's a part of that Club
people throw money at the problem
whether it's paying the person off or
hiring a team of lawyers powerful people
use money as a shield this is why I love
these people just were silent it's a
very hard and powerful thing to to fight
child abuse experts say they treat two
to three hundred cases of sexual abuse
in Los Angeles every year as part of a
two-month operation targeting child
predators in Southern California LA
police made 238 arrests in 2016 it takes
that inner strength to come forward now
with children it's that inner strength
that you know it it's not the same as
with an adult they feel like they've
done something wrong and they feel
guilty and it's very difficult to come
and talk about it because you not even
sure you're a victim
Hollywood might not like talking about
it but it doesn't take a lot of digging
to find even more examples of how it
often has selective amnesia when it
comes to some of the past behavior of
those it chooses to welcome into the
fold if we look historically what's been
going on I mean we how long ago was that
that Mel Gibson was completely derided
in this town and is now being lauded for
his work and we've seen it you know
we've seen these scandals for Roman
Polanski and for Woody Allen we've seen
these scams become very public and then
a few years passes and they're being
given money for more projects the Harvey
Weinstein scandal shows how the industry
can turn a blind eye exposing how those
close to him appear to have been
complicit in protecting the producer
keeping quiet about accusations of
sexual assault and rape which Weinstein
denies there's been a domino effect of
people coming forward with allegations
of misconduct others who have been
accused include Tyler gray Sherman agent
for one of the stars of stranger things
who was fired following claims he raped
an 18 year old and with allegations
mounting Kevin Spacey has apologized to
actor Anthony Rapp for sexual harassment
when he was 14
and it's prompted questions over why
roman polanski continues to be decorated
with industry awards despite a
conviction for raping a 13 year old
power that comes with fame seems to make
some untouchable
I think Fame ultimately corrupts you
know I think a lot of famous people will
say that they don't change when they
become famous but people change towards
them when they're famous and the the
famous people that I've known of hang up
with they live in a very weird world
where everything they say is hilarious
people are running around are from all
the time it's it's naturally and
ultimately corrupting in some way you're
not seeing the world in a normal way so
your whole level of what is right and
wrong ultimately adjusts in 2004 actor
Brian Peck was convicted of sex with a
child but just two years later he was
given a role on this kids show The Suite
Life of Zack and Cody it's been working
as a dialogue coach on anger management
speaking to someone familiar with the
show we were told the decision to hire
Brian Peck came down to Charlie Sheen
himself an investigation was actually
carried out after a complaint was made
by one of the crew who learnt about his
background the recommendations were
though because some time had passed he
was going to be allowed to stay on set
providing though children were present
and his time off sets would be limited
to Charlie Sheen's trailer I mean you
gotta realize how many Studios may have
protected people that he knew what was
going what they were doing wrong you
know that knew it should have got rid of
a long time ago and you know so these
are corporate situations that they don't
want to get rid of people because
they're making money for them so they
don't want to get rid of them so they
keep them even though they're
victimizing people
[Music]
Todd bridges who start in one of the 70s
biggest sitcoms was molested by his
publicist at the time that it was going
on from 11:00 to 12:00 I didn't know
when I was you know because you know
you're a little kid you don't have any
idea what you are I had never had sexual
encounters or anything so when that man
did that to me you know he grew me grew
me very well secrets is what kills
secrets will kill you
you can't hold secrets inside that's
what destroys you I'm one of the few
children you know that have you know got
rid of it and still around
most of my protegees have died or he
commits suicide or od'd you know because
they couldn't get over and stuff that
happened to them Corey Feldman and Corey
Haim two of the biggest child stars of
the 80s both said they were abused by
pedophiles during that time before his
death Haines claimed he'd been raped
aged 11 on social media Feldman now says
it's high time those who knew speak up I
know that there's thousands others that
have experienced what I've experienced
in the entertainment industry I also
know that there's peers of mine who know
exactly what I'm talking about and know
all the details but have been afraid to
come forward with their own truths I am
using this to draw a line in the sand to
say to the Hollywood community we are
better than this but we'll what's
happening in Hollywood now be enough of
a catalyst to finally force the film
industry to oust its abusers personally
I'd like to see responsibility with
anyone working with children or or a
child with an extensive background
checked it goes back to where the
industry or where the company draws the
line
powerful people have responsibility for
the people they employ I think it's they
should have systems in place to protect
the people that are working for them
that's responsible management whether
you're a woman or a male or a child or
an adult if you're being abused you're
being abused and we should as victims
and survivors should all band together
and stick together and and really
there's strength in numbers you know so
I'm really hoping that that through this
exposure more people will come forward
just have to look at what's going on
with young women we know they're not
being protected so what makes us think
that anyone else is being protected that
this is this is opening up I think a big
can of worms for Hollywood I think there
are a lot of people who probably have
not said their experiences and but
eventually I think they will once they
feel safe enough and you realize that
the script has been ripped up now the
focus is on Hollywood itself before it
can tell other people's stories it's now
under increasing pressure to act on its
own dark reality